all right
[Music]
[Applause]
Kevin Costner and his wife Christine
going their separate ways after 18 years
of marriage you don't know what people
are going to feel
a rep for the actor confirms the split
in a statement telling ET that due to
circumstances Beyond his control
Christine's dissolution of marriage
filing is moving forward we're not shy
at all about running our Ranch
ET was at Kevin's Aspen Ranch when he
and his wife Christine got married there
in 2004. we needed to get her to the
spot back in January it was announced
the 160 acre estate was available to
rent
I've never seen it from here
hey look it looks like a field
oh my goodness the Field of Dreams right
yeah without the corn without the corn
exactly it's pretty corny
the couple shares three kids Kaden Hayes
and Grace Kevin's rep ends a statement
on Tuesday by asking that the family's
privacy be respected as they navigate
this difficult time
foreign